und jetzt das heute journal
windsurfer richter und christian sievers
guten abend den 1
der britische parlamentspräsident hat
mal erzählt wie er mittlerweile selbst
von deutschen touristen angesprochen
wird
die ihn bitten für sie mal schnell oder
zu brüllen
damit ist jetzt schluss erstens weil
john bercow heute seinen rücktritt
angekündigt hat und zweitens weil das
britische parlament hat heute abend in
die zwangspause geht der premierminister
will das so fünf wochen lang will sich
boris johnson damit lästige debatten und
beschlüsse vom hals halten
vorher allerdings hat eine mehrheit im
unterhaus noch mal klar gemacht was es
von johnsons vorgehen in sachen braig
cit hält nämlich nichts
das ist ein weiterer denkwürdig
chaotischer tag in der wiege des
parlamentarismus aus london diana
zimmermann
sie werden in die zwangspause geschickt
aber sie gehen nicht widerstandslos
sechs niederlagen haben die
parlamentarier boris johnson in seiner
kurzen amtszeit schon beschert ihr ziel
ist es heute mit sieben zu null nach
hause zu gehen
am frühen abend stimmte eine mehrheit
dafür dass die regierung ihren gesamten
schriftverkehr rund um den chaos bei
exit offenlegen muss und spät am abend
werden sie den premier wohl noch einmal
den wunsch verweigern waren schon im
oktober abzuhalten
wir werden alles tun was wir können um
zu verhindern dass es am 31 oktober
einen exit ohne deal gibt und wenn das
geschehen ist wählen wir seit heute ist
auch gesetz dass johnson in brüssel um
eine verschiebung des brachse bitten
muss wenn er vom parlament keinen neuen
vertrag mit der eu genehmigt bekommt
während immer verrücktere gerüchte
kursieren wie es ihm doch noch gelingen
könnte den kaos braig cit gegen den
willen des parlaments durchzuziehen gab
der premier sich heute zu gast in irland
mal staatsmännisch stadt draufgängerisch
ich will einen deal erreichen wie sie
habe ich mir den dreck cit ohne deal
sehr genau angeschaut und seine
konsequenzen für unsere länder abgewogen
wir könnten das natürlich schaffen
großbritannien können
sicherlich aber man darf sich nicht
täuschen ein solches ergebnis käme einem
politischen scheitern gleich für das wir
alle die verantwortung tragen würde und
was aber stellt johnson sich vor wie
kann das ist die entscheidende frage die
grenze zwischen nordirland und irland
offen bleiben wenn der austritt
großbritanniens dort eine eu-grenze
schafft der ire freundlich aber hart wir
sind offen für alternativen aber sie
müssen funktionieren realistisch sein
und vertraglich bindend und heute haben
wir keine vorschläge erhalten keine
vorschläge kein deal kein austritt am
31.10
immerhin ist seit heute sicher dass es
ende oktober wenigstens einen abschied
geben wird john bercow der sprecher des
unterhauses wortgewaltiger kämpfer für
die rechte des parlaments hat seinen
rückzug erklärt nicht ohne mahnende
worte an das haus dem er zehn jahre lang
vorstand es ist die pflicht der
abgeordneten nicht als die delegierten
der wähler sondern als ihre vertreter
das zu tun was ihnen richtig scheint für
das land wenn wir dieses parlament klein
machen schadet das nur uns beifall für
den konservativen kam auch das
bezeichnend für die ungewöhnlichen
zeiten hier vor allem von den bänken der
opposition
wir werden seine krawatten vermissen und
wir müssen uns ein bisschen die augen
reiben denn der britische aussenminister
hat heute bekräftigt die regierung werde
sich ans gesetz halten
diana guten abend nach london das
vertrauen darauf scheint nicht so
wahnsinnig weit gediehen zu sein einer
parlamentsmehrheit hat heute entschieden
dass die regierung interne kommunikation
offenlegen muss in sachen brax it was
vermutet man denn da wenn man vermutet
dass die regierung sehr viel mehr
darüber was die folgen eines chaotischen
braig sind als dass sie es zugeben
möchte und man erhofft sich eben das
durch die offenlegung dieser dokumente
unter anderem eben privater e-mails von
regierungsmitarbeitern klar wird dass
dieser chaotische dragset vollkommen und
zumutbar ist für das land so dass eben
auch klar wird wie unverantwortlich die
regierung johnson damit pokert in den
verhandlungen mit brüssel
tatsächlich ist es aber auch ein
symbolischer sieg eben über eine
regierung der hier die opposition nur
noch sehr sehr wenig vertrauen
entgegenbringt eigentlich gar keins und
das war eben genau das was dominik graf
heute abend im grunde genommen noch mal
bekräftigt hat in dem er gesagt hat
'natürlich werde sich die regierung an
das gesetz halten dessen ist man sich
nicht mehr sicher die regierung tut so
als stünde sie über dem gesetz vor allem
aber über dem parlament die andere wir
wissen jetzt was nicht geht ein gesetz
verbietet den ungeregelten brachse zum
31 oktober es wird wohl heute abend ein
gesetz kommen dass es auch keine
neuwahlen geben wird bis ende oktober
was wir noch nicht wissen ist was geht
denn tatsächlich es ist natürlich
möglich dass johnson doch noch bis zum
17 18 oktober einen deal mit brüssel
verhandelt dagegen spricht dass brüssel
sagt es gibt immer noch keine vorschläge
deswegen ist es sehr wahrscheinlich dass
die verschiebung kommt bis zum 31 2020
die verschiebung des black sind
johnston sagt er wird das sich
beantragen aber vielleicht muss es dann
eben jemand anderes tun die andere
grosse wahrscheinlichkeit sind neuwahlen
nicht im oktober aber im november und
dann ist natürlich wieder alles drin
gar kein bier exit der super harte
bresset die möglichkeit aber auch in
durchaus dass es wieder keine klaren
mehrheiten gibt sondern einfach
verlängerte
ratlosigkeit das ist wie in einer
dauerschleife herzlichen dank
die haben uns immer noch heute abend
nach london unser nächstes thema
der lack ist noch nicht ab aber eher
bröckelt die iaa war mal der treffpunkt
der internationalen autowelt messe
frankfurt ausverkaufte hallen
erwartungsfrohe publikum schulterklopfen
bei den managern
es war einmal die messe läuft ab heute
wieder aber sie ist geschrumpft und noch
entscheidender die branche ist
verunsichert sie versucht einen spagat
der schwierig auszuhalten ist die iaa
soll keine ps leistungsschau mehr sein
sondern eine mobilitätsmesse die
hersteller stellen ihre autos ins
rampenlicht geld verdienen sie aber
weiter mit kraftstrotzenden limousinen
und suvs wie lange geht das noch gut das
ist die große frage in frankfurt dominik
löschmeister berichtet hierauf setzt der
vw konzern seine hoffnungen weltpremiere
des neuen a3 am abend in frankfurt das
modell soll hat mit den nächsten jahres
kommen das e-auto massentauglich werden
nie zuvor war die autoindustrie bei
einer iaa so unter druck
ich finde die proteste verständlich wir
sind in einer zeit in der der
klimawandel einfach viele betrieb viele
fühlen sich betroffen viele haben das
gefühl die industrie die politik tut zu
wenig und ich glaube wir haben allen
grund uns damit auseinanderzusetzen
unter 30.000 euro soll der id3 kosten
reichweite bis 550 kilometer auch opel
hat mit dem corsa ab 2020 ein
elektroauto in der gleichen preisspanne
im angebot die industrie verspricht zu
liefern
doch bisher führen elektroautos eher ein
schatten dasein im ersten halbjahr 2009
10 wurden rund 1,8 millionen pkw in
deutschland neu zugelassen
der anteil der benziner rund 59 prozent
diesel fahrzeuge erreichen 33 prozent
die elektroautos liegen bei mageren 17
prozent der hybrid anteil immerhin
schafft 56 prozent marktanteil
die drei größten hürden beim elektroauto
sind heute erstens der preis ist hoch
zweite streich weiter und drittens ist
die infrastruktur gerade in großstädten
äußerst lückenhaft
die kunden greifen eher zum suv kein
fahrzeug segment wächst so schnell wie
die stadt geländewagen mit keinem
verdienen die hersteller mehr geld ja
die menschen lieben suv sondern wir bei
opel haben kompakte suvs nehmen sie als
beispiel den great lakes als kompakten
suv mit einer länge von vier metern 45
und den bieten wir jetzt auch mit einem
plug in hybrid an die kritiker dagegen
fordern die abkehr vom suv das ende des
verbrennungsmotors die unter dem
pseudonym auftretende aktivistin tenor
velo will die ira am wochenende
blockieren
wir werden durchaus die grenze des
legalen protestdemonstrationen
überschreiten das heißt wir werden
blockieren wir werden ganz ruhig und
besonnen mit unseren körpern blockieren
diese messe und eben damit versuchen den
ablauf der messe zu stören
der volkswagen chef stellt sich am
frühen abend den kritikern verpflichtet
sich zum ausbau der e mobilität gibt
aber die bedeutung der industrie hervor
wir müssen natürlich diesen wandel zu
schaffen und der sehr christlich geplant
dass wir auch diese arbeitsplätze
zunächst ein großteil dieser
arbeitsplätze über diesen über handel
das ist die herausforderung für eine
industrie die sich immer mehr
rechtfertigen muss so steht die krise
der iaa in diesem jahr sinnbildlich für
die probleme der gesamten branche
also wir haben gesehen wie schleppend
dass mit der e auto zukunft läuft in
deutschland
wie stellen sich die autofirmen denn
dann ihr geld verdienen in der zukunft
vor frank bethmann die alten
gewinnbringer irgendwie ausquetschen bis
es wirklich nicht mehr weiter geht ja
derzeit sieht es tatsächlich danach aus
als trage eben bereits an die großen suv
ist die boom allein die marke vw will in
den kommenden jahren ihre suv palette
von 11 auf 30 ausweiten und liegt damit
voll im trend der anteil der kraftprotz
am absatz der hersteller wächst von jahr
zu jahr beträgt bei mercedes-benz
mittlerweile über 32 prozent bei audi
gas und 40 noch getoppt von bmw mit fast
44 prozent
was sie so toll anhört ist eben in
wahrheit die achillesferse der deutschen
automobilindustrie denn erfolg wird
künftig nicht mehr in gewinnmarge pro
auto mal die verkaufte stückzahl
gemessen erfolg bekommt im neuen jahr
eine wichtige komponente dazu wie
umweltfreundlich ist eigentlich das
verkaufte fahrzeug ab 2020 müssen alle
autohersteller den durchschnittlichen
verbrauch ihrer in europa verkauften
autos auf 95 gramm pro kilometer drücken
zum vergleich das neue bmw flaggschiff
in der suv klasse der x7 liegt bei rund
200 gramm je kilometer klimatechnisch
sind die suv ist also eine katastrophe
dass bei einer überschreitung der
klimaziele milliarden strafen drohen
ignoriert die branche bislang das könnte
sich schon bald rächen wenn ich doch
noch ein radikales umdenken stattfindet
frank vielen dank und um die zukunft der
suvs läuft in deutschland ja noch eine
ganz andere debatte seit dem
schrecklichen unfall in berlin am
freitagabend mit vier toten
es ist eine sicherheitsdebatte dazu hat
heute de viele fakten zusammengetragen
unter anderem zur unfallstatistik der
geländewagen und es gibt dort auch eine
abstimmung über die frage sollten suvs
aus innenstädten verbannt werden alles
auf heute.de und jetzt hier im fernsehen
nachrichten mit kassel ein neues
gütesiegel gibt ab sofort auskunft
darüber ob ein kleidungsstück weitgehend
fair produziert wurde der grüne knopf
steht für soziale und ökologische
mindeststandards
märz und wurde heute von
bundesentwicklungsminister müller
vorgestellt
menschenrechtler sowie umwelt- und
verbraucherschützer kritisieren dass das
label auf freiwilligkeit setzt und nicht
alle produktionsschritte erfasst auch
die textilindustrie ist skeptisch ein
nationales siegel sei in einem globalen
markt sinnlos die kommunal und
regionalwahlen in russland haben ein
gemischtes ergebnis gebracht
in den meisten regionen bleibt die
regierungspartei dominant in moskau hat
sie stark verloren
von den 45 stadtrat sitzen dort gewann
die opposition 20 13 mehr als vor fünf
jahren
die wahlen gelten auch als stimmungstest
für präsident putin zahlreiche
oppositionskandidaten durften dabei
nicht antreten was zu wochenlangen
heftigen protesten führten kehrtwende im
hessischen altenstadt waldsiedlung dort
soll der rechtsextreme neuer
ortsvorsteher jagsch wieder abgewählt
werden
man habe sich mit spd und fdp auf einen
entsprechenden antrag verständigt so die
cdu kreisvorsitzende puttrich damit
zeichnet sich auch die erforderliche
zwei drittel mehrheit ab jack hatte für
diesen fall bereits rechtliche schritte
angekündigt die wahl des npd funktionärs
hatte bundesweit empörung ausgelöst
bei einem taifun sind in japan
mindestens drei menschen getötet und 50
verletzt worden
der wirbelsturm traf bei tokio auf das
festland mit windgeschwindigkeiten von
mehr als 200 kilometern pro stunde und
enormen regenmengen weil etliche
hochspannungsmasten umknicken waren fast
eine million haushalte ohne strom
und auch der öffentliche nahverkehr
brach zusammen zehntausende pendler
saßen stundenlang fest für die kinder
nur das beste das nehmen sich die
allermeisten eltern vor das ist das
credo einer zivilisierten gesellschaft
daran muss sich auch der start messen
lassen
bildung ist das a und o der satz kommt
in jeder politiker sonntagsrede vor
er stimmt weil es um chancen geht für
die zukunft die zukunft nicht nur jedes
einzelnen kindes die zukunft unserer
welt insgesamt
aber dann schauen wir uns die lage in
deutschland an und sehen es bröckelt der
putz in den schulen manche toiletten
dort sind in einem
man muss das so sagen ekelhaften zustand
es gibt absurde bürokratie
es fehlt gar nicht mal immer nur geld es
fehlt an handwerkern an einfachen
strukturen und es fehlen bald massiv
lehrerinnen und lehrer in den
grundschulen und zwar viele tausend mehr
als ohnehin schon befürchtet heute
schlagen bildungsforscher alarm
ulrike riedel risse im boden löcher in
den wänden und decken die sich lösen
dauerbaustelle schule das georg büchner
gymnasium in köln weiden 1400 kinder
gehen hier zur schule ab nächstes jahr
bekommen sie ein neues schulgebäude 13
jahre lang haben sie darauf gewartet
mich ärgert ist dass wir als schüler
hier an dieser schule arbeiten sollen
wir sollen hier lernen das lernen von
oder fordert meines erachtens ein gutes
lernumfeld ein schönes lernumfeld und
das ist hier an der schule nicht gegeben
mich persönlich ärgert ist dass so wenig
unternommen wird obwohl so viel
versprochen wird die fenster die aus dem
rahmen fallen oder ähnliches sind nicht
unbedingt immer super
umso lernen zu können wie wir es haben
wollen köln weiden ist kein einzelfall
etwa 400.000 schulen gibt es in
deutschland viele davon sind in den 60er
und 70er jahren gebaut und inzwischen
marode
das problem obwohl bund und länder seit
jahren geld ins system pumpen es reicht
nicht
knapp 43 milliarden euro fehlen aktuell
für die sanierung von schulen so die
berechnung der kreditanstalt für
wiederaufbau
die bildung in deutschland im eimer
finden die die es unmittelbar betrifft
deshalb sind sie in mainz und
demonstrieren ihr thema lehrermangel
man baut wieder habt anstatt einfach zu
sagen wir stellen ja man hat alles
zurück gefahren und jetzt merkt man
brüste spät ist wieder das muss man
lehrer besorgen es fällt so viel
unterricht aus dass wir kaum genug
lernen können weiteren leben einfach
voranzukommen und ist unmöglich einfach
einer aktuellen studie zufolge fehlen
bis 2025 etwa 30.000 lehrer allein in
den grund- und förderschulen kostenpunkt
rund 1,3 milliarden euro
ja die zahl der schüler die heute die
schulen besuchen hat man vor fünf jahren
unterschätzt
natürlich gab's sondereffekt wir haben
eine hohe zuwanderung auch aus der eu
die dazu führt dass wir mehr schüler
haben die auch ein platz an der schule
brauchen von daher ist das system jetzt
in vielen engpässen gefangen und die
gilt es dann systematisch abzubauen
lehrermangel dass es doch eines der
probleme die birgit schlesinger lösen
muss sie ist seit fünf jahren
schuldirektorin seitdem kämpft sie dafür
mehr lehrer zu bekommen
wir haben hier abgeordnete
förderschullehrer aber lange nicht in
dem umfang wie sie uns zu stehen warum
nicht weil wir nicht genügend lehrer
haben gute lernbedingungen ein kraftakt
für lehrer und schüler immerhin bekommen
die schüler hier bald eine mensa auch
dafür hat die schulleiterin lange
kämpfen müssen
anja karliczek cdu ist die
bundesbildungsministerin bildung ist in
diesem land sache der länder aber wie
unsere schulen aussehen und was da an
massiven lehrermangel auf uns zukommt
das muss jedoch auch interessieren guten
am vortag oder guten abend herr sievers
natürlich interessiert mich dass wir
sind bildungsland hier in deutschland
wir wollen bildungsrepublik sein und
insofern interessiert es mich natürlich
dass wir einige sorgen haben aber
vielleicht kann man vorweg mal erst
sagen wir haben seit dem pisa-schock
2000 gute fortschritte gemacht in ein in
ein mittleres bildungsniveau zu kommen
und genau an der stelle wollen wir jetzt
weiter arbeiten und vielleicht darf man
auch mal eins sagen
viele viele gute lehrer in unserem land
haben wir die eben auch gute arbeit
leisten die unsere kinder gut
unterrichten und sehr sehr sehr viele
gute lehrer fehlen in diesem land wenn
man den bildungsforschern glaubt 30.000
grundschullehrer bis 2025 die kann man
ja nicht einfach so backen die müssen ja
jetzt bereits studieren wenn sie dann
tatsächlich für die kleinen kinder am
start sein sollen rechtzeitig das wird
nicht klappen was empfehlen sie denn
jetzt in so einer notlage
ja ich glaube wir sollten uns an der
stelle ehrlich machen und auch sagen
dass die lehrer ausbildung in unserem
land sieben jahre dauert dass wir auch
dieses problem des lehrermangels gerade
auch in den grundschulen nicht in der
kurzen frist lösen können aber wir
müssen uns natürlich trotzdem jetzt auf
den weg machen wir brauchen bessere
prognosen wir brauchen mehr plätze in
den hochschulen für die lehrer
ausbildung und was wir natürlich auch
brauchen wir brauchen eine
übergangslösung und ich denke da sind
quereinsteiger auch eine gute lösung
jetzt ist ja nicht so dass die kinder
direkt nach der geburt in die
grundschule kommen insofern ist da eine
zeitspanne da warum ist es so schwer die
zu erkennen und in den sechs jahren
tatsächlich angemessen zu planen
weil ich gerade bei der planung und bei
der prognose fähigkeit immer so viele
komponenten gebiet zueinander zu bringen
sind es macht jedes bundesland für sich
wird dann in der kmk zusammengesetztes
hat auch alles lenkt
kultusministerkonferenz in der
kultusministerkonferenz das hat einen
vorlauf aber natürlich müssen wir diese
prognose fähigkeiten verbessern
das mit der bildungsrepublik das
versprechen uns die politiker jetzt
allerdings schon seit jahren gerade auch
was die maroden schulen angeht die
schlimmen zustände in vielen schulen wir
haben gerade im beitrag gesehen
da ist es ja so dass durchaus geld
mittlerweile im spiel ist da sind
milliarden auch vom bund im spiel aber
die scheinen nicht richtig anzukommen
und das macht ja vielleicht die eltern
und lehrer und die schüler am ende noch
viel wütender kurzes beispiel ein
schulsanierungsprogramm läuft seit 2017
3780 maßnahmen sind da vorgesehen da
sieht man schon wie groß das problem ist
3780 und abgeschlossen sind bisher 27
das kann doch nicht wahr sein oder
genau wir haben 2017 das
schulsanierungsprogramm mit 3,5
milliarden euro vom bundestag
auf den weg gebracht die umsetzung muss
natürlich vor ort geschehen und wir
haben gerade in der umsetzung in unserem
land vielfach im moment ein stauber wir
gar nicht so viel
soviel handwerker haben und so viel also
planungsbüros haben die all diese ganzen
maßnahmen planen können in der
geschwindigkeit wie es im moment
angebracht wäre
die länder prüfen ob die gemeinden die
kriterien erfüllen für gelder der bund
kontrolliert dann ob die länder die
gelder korrekt vergeben
das wirkt jetzt schon mal sehr sehr
bürokratisch wie oft verzweifeln sie
dann am föderalismus in deutschland bei
dem thema grundsätzlich halte ich den
föderalismus für einen guten weg dass
wir vor ort immer die richtigen
maßnahmen relativ schnell treffen können
deswegen ist es auch wichtig das haben
wir beim digital packt ja so gemacht
dass wir uns darauf geeinigt haben erst
muss vor ort ein konzept erstellt werden
damit vor ort gesagt werden kann was
wird gebraucht dann machen die länder
die weiterbildung und dann gibt der bund
das geld für die infrastruktur
wir sind immer an der stelle zuständig
wo wir unterstützung geben können für
infrastruktur in der umsetzung aber eben
auch für den betrieb der schulen sind
immer die länder mit den kommunen
zusammen zuständig und da muss dann eben
auch die umsetzung passieren von karl
jenkins irre viel geld da haben sie
gerade gesagt die umsetzung hapert aber
erheblich es kommt also mit anderen
worten nicht bei denen an die es
dringend brauchen nämlich bei den
schülern was können sie besorgten
schülern besorgten eltern besorgten
lehrern heute abend konkret versprechen
dass wir mit dem nationalen bildungsrat
uns genau diese themen noch mal
anschauen wir haben das thema
bildungsstandards bildungs transparenz
und auch vergleichbarkeit zwischen
schulsystemen für eltern die von einem
bundesland ins andere ziehen mit dem
bildungsrat jetzt auf die tat mit dem
nationalen bildungsrat auf die tagen
tagungsort tagesordnung gesehen aber vor
panik wir kennen doch die probleme wir
müssen uns jedoch nicht alle noch mal
anschauen
wir haben aber die wir haben aber die
herausforderung wenn wir sie
flächendeckend in deutschland lösen
wollen dann brauchen wir zwischen dem
was wir theoretisch haben und der
praktischen umsetzung brauchen wir
glaube ich schon noch mal unterstützung
denn es ändern sich die herausforderung
auch ständig dir der digital packt die
digitale das digitale lernen digitale
bildung ist etwas was ich in den
nächsten jahren
ja sehr stark entwickelt und dafür
brauchen wir ein gremium mit dem wir das
für alle ebenen von der frühkindlichen
bildung bis in die berufliche bildung
auch immer wieder durchspielen können
und dadurch auch immer wieder passende
empfehlungen bekommen die dann in den
ländern umgesetzt werden müssen also
zwischen theorie und praxis klafft doch
noch eine lücke frau carlitscheck
herzlichen dank für das gespräch heute
abend gerne und das gespräch war aus
termingründen vor 90 minuten
aufgezeichnet keine server noch mal die
große koalition will in zwölf
handwerksberufen die meisterpflicht
einführen
zum beispiel für raumausstatter fliesen
oder parkettleger das sei die beste
garantie für qualitätsarbeit
verbraucherschutz leistungsfähigkeit und
innovationskraft heißt es in einer
gemeinsamen erklärung
der zentralverband des handwerks drängt
schon lange auf eine rückkehr zur
meisterpflicht sie wurde 2004 in 52
berufen abgeschafft
in den usa sind groß angelegter
ermittlungen gegen google angelaufen
48 bundesstaaten sowie der
regierungsbezirk washington dc und
puerto rico haben sich der initiative
eines texanischen staatsanwaltes
angeschlossen
er will klären ob google seine
marktmacht ausnutzte um den wettbewerb
bei internet werbung zu behindern
die untersuchung könnte sich noch auf
andere bereiche ausweiten
ein sieg musste her nach der pleite
gegen die niederlande in der em
qualifikation ging es für die fußball
nationalmanschaft vorhin um wichtige
punkte und die hat sie aufgeholt mit
einem etwas mühevollen 2 zu 0 geben
die erleichterung nach dem abpfiff bei
joachim löw und den seinen wohl auch
deshalb so groß weil es lange zeit auf
messers schneide stand das spiel in dem
die nordiren die erste großchance für
sich verbuchen konnten kurz vor der
pause manuel neuer aber am ende mit
glück und geschick
fast im gegenzug auch das dfb team nun
endlich mit der möglichkeit zur führung
durch die moderne aber keine tore zur
halbzeit doch mit dem seitenwechsel
veränderte sich auch das spiel und es
kam bewegung auf die anzeigetafel nach
diesem wundervollen treffer von marcel
halstenberg erstes pflichtspiel von
beginn an und dann dieser tolle
premieren treffer all das passierte in
der 48 minute anschließend verpasste es
die deutsche mannschaft jedoch das
ergebnis zu erhöhen und damit das spiel
zu beruhigen es herrscht hier noch um
zentimeter am ziel vorbei in der
nachspielzeit hingegen gewohnt
treffsicher neuntes tor im zehnten
länderspiel dann war schluss und die
erleichterung groß
kein wunder bei einem spiel das so lange
auf messers schneide stand
es liegt etwas in der luft heute vor
genau 30 jahren in grünheide östlich von
berlin
ein unscheinbares zweistöckiges haus
eine gruppe von bürgerrechtlern die zwei
dinge für sich ganz klar wissen erstens
sie wollen bleiben in der ddr und
zweitens sie wollen dass sich etwas
ändert in osteuropa brodelt ist doch
erich honecker sein sed politbüro und
die stasi glauben weitermachen zu können
als sei nichts passiert
um zu verstehen was diesen haben vor 30
jahren in dem haus bei berlin zu einem
historischen machtwechsel führen dass es
damals keine handys gab und keine
digital vernetzte gesellschaft
es gab einen aufruf ein schreibmaschine
getippten flugblatt das innerhalb
kürzester zeit die gesamte ddr
elektrisierte es gab das neue forum
christian von rechenberg erinnert das
neue forum ist gerade mal zwei monate
alt da erlebt die ddr die größte
demonstration aller zeiten und die junge
bürgerrechtsbewegung erlebt welche wucht
sie entfaltet wenn sie die stimme erhebt
etwa für freien zugang zu den medien
das neue forum brennt darauf dass
gähnende loch aufzufüllen dass der
schwarze kanal hinterlassen hat das neue
forum superstar hat das land mobilisiert
geweckt die jens reich heute sagt in
berlin redet er wieder vor kleinerem
publikum über das was ihn angetrieben
hat als die mauer begann zu bröckeln
die vorstellung dass alle unsere kinder
und dann später die enkelkinder dass die
alle im westen sein würden und wir uns
vielleicht nicht mehr sehen dürfen weil
wieder die mauer noch höher ist also
damals schon war die war denke ich ganz
stark motivierend wir wollten nicht
allein zurückbleiben
sie wollten demokratie rechtsstaat
freiheit 30 männer und frauen ihr neues
forum nimmt am 9
september 1989 die arbeit auf mit einem
aufruf in unserem land ist die
kommunikation zwischen staat und
gesellschaft offensichtlich gestört ein
paukenschlag
das lag gerade daran dass er eben nicht
so viel programm nicht so viel inhalte
hatte sondern einfach nur
unzufriedenheit und veränderungsbedarf
auf den punkt gebracht mehrere
hunderttausend unterschreiten den aufruf
strömen zu den veranstaltungen des neuen
forums das bald 10.000 mitglieder hat
ein tanz auf der klinge massenflucht in
ungarn auf ruhe daheim die sed ist
hochnervös zu allem fähig und am ende
überfordert bürgerrechtler schaffen
fakten der zentrale runde tisch der ddr
zwingt die regierung auf augenhöhe und
ins kreuzverhör
das neue forum will eine demokratische
runderneuerung der ddr erst mal ohne
wiedervereinigung der dritte weg aber
der kommt beim volk nicht mehr an
als die mauer schließlich fällt
liebesentzug bei der ersten freien wahl
zur volkskammer 1990 mit anderen gruppen
geht das neue forum ein wahlbündnis ein
bündnis 90 bekommt magere zwölf sitze
mission erfüllt
im wiedervereinigten deutschland wird
das neue forum nicht mehr gebraucht und
lebt in teilen weiter in einer partei
die mit dem bündnis der bürgerrechtler
zusammenwächst
vor allen dingen hat es grün auch
geprägt grün geprägt indem in den
einsatz für menschenrechte in denen in
denen verständnis dafür dass wir
hinschauen wenn demokratiebewegung sich
auf die straße begeben um für freiheit
für menschenrechte einzutreten was
bleibt vom neuen forum vielleicht auch
dass ihr leben als freie bürger in einem
freien land dies zu verteidigen ist
aktueller denn je
damit lassen wir sie in diesem
montagabend danke dass sie bei uns waren
und hoffentlich bis morgen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren tief hans
liegt zurzeit hier etwa über tschechien
und der slowakei und zieht bis morgen
weiter in richtung ostsee und dann
richtung schweden und sie sehen sehr
schön wie sich dieses tief ein klingelt
es verwirbelt warme luft aus richtung
südosteuropa und kühlere luft aus
arktischen breiten bei uns und das macht
sich dann auch sofort bei den
höchsttemperaturen mitteleuropa
bemerkbar denn so liegen die höchstwerte
zwischen dänemark und der danziger bucht
nur bei 16 grad im süden schwedens sind
ist dagegen 23 grad
und dieses tief hat natürlich auch
auswirkungen unsere nachttemperaturen
das tief hält warm mit seinen
regenwolken deswegen sinken die werte im
nordosten nicht unter 14 bis 10 grad
deutlich kühler wird im rest von
deutschland und kältesten am alpenrand
dort geht es bis 2 grad runter das
bedeutet dort droht bodenfrost denn da
ist der himmel leben häufig klar an der
donau bildet sich auch mal nebel
nordöstlich der elbe schüttet ist jetzt
in der nacht noch heftig weiter auch
morgen über tag regnet es dann auch erst
zum abend lassen dann die regenfälle
auch in mecklenburg vorpommern nach
dafür nimmt der wind böig zu das ist ein
starker bis stürmischer wind aus
westlichen richtungen
sonst wechseln sonne und wolken und die
nebelfelder der donau
die sollten sich alle auflösen
temperaturen liegen zwischen 16 und 22
grad und dann wird es von tag zu tag
etwas wärmer wobei es nicht überall für
26 grad erreicht wie hier zum beispiel
in freiburg im breisgau
schönen abend noch